hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well how should we
understand what it means to be not just
a peer or to think what self to be but
actually be a philosopher this is
something that I can see does it talks
about quite a bit throughout the
entirety of the discourse is often
making a distinction between those who
merely study philosophy or think they're
up for lecturing on it and those who
really put it into practice because for
epictetus that's going to be one of the
hallmarks and this is not a new problem
by the way you can see this being
discussed in Plato's Republic where he
talks about all the people who present
themselves as philosophers giving
philosophy of that name so by the time
that Epictetus is treating this it's
it's been a for several centuries at
least now the key question that we want
to think about is what is really
essential to the role of the philosopher
and when I say the philosopher I
actually mean the stoic philosopher
because epictetus although he
understands that there are other schools
he thinks that they are mistaken in some
respects you know the Brazilians are a
little bit lacks on some things they
have the Koreans well they're way off
the cynics they're actually on the right
tract but it's so difficult to be a
cynic he's focusing on what the stoic
philosopher who ought to be like and
what this gives us is a really great
insight into how he understands his own
practice which he's actually if you read
through the discourses rather heard of
himself that points and saying that he
doesn't completely measure up himself
now he begins in part with this this
section by talking about the mistaken
viewpoints of the many and of what he
doesn't call we could call today the
dilettante those who are just engaged in
reading and talking about philosophy but
not really internalizing it not as he
says in another section digesting it and
making it part of their bones and and
singers and what can we say about this
they identify the philosopher with the
external appearances of the philosopher
now in his time what did that mean so
I'll read you what he actually has to
say how do you know that somebody's a
philosopher because he wears a rough
cloak and long hair now in other points
people thought philosophers well you
know somebody is a philosopher because
they have a beard you know nowadays we
might say other things like well they
have a position in a philosophy
department so they must be a philosopher
you know who knows we haven't we have
all sorts of things we could talk about
philosophers these days are a little bit
more diverse in their appearance but
there are certain things we might be
able to identify it with particularly
for zeroing in on certain approaches in
in philosophy they tend to acquire a
certain kind of style one of my my
teachers when I was in graduate school
who was as you might say two generations
removed from MIT consign she was a bit
consign scholar she told us about these
people who had studied with Vicki and
shine who had begun to after they become
professors and they were teaching to
imitate his mannerisms and so they would
do you know
disconcerting things like when asked a
question go over in the corner and just
put their head against the wall because
it was the sort of thing that he had
done now epictetus you know whatever
sort of thing we're talking about in
this epoch to use to say that is zero to
do with philosophy you can do philosophy
just as well in a t-shirt as you can in
a jacket or a tie or you know a costume
is its philosophy so it's not so
dependent on external appearances and
then there was a dynamic that takes
place he says that what they do is they
identify philosophers with those who
wear the right things and then they see
the philosophers that you notice I put
it here in quotes behaving badly not
measuring up to what it is that they're
talking about and then they draw the
wrong conclusions now you know why do
they draw the wrong conclusions about
that because they're they're beginning
from the erroneous starting when I'm
thinking that philosophers identified by
appearance there's a sort of
self-fulfilling cycle to this because
they become confused about it and then
they don't respect the profession of
philosopher well they're also coming to
the wrong conclusions in part because of
that very fact that they are confused
about what it means to be a philosopher
they know perspective let's see what he
actually has to say about about this he
says judgments about skills or actions
or roles are not really determined by
externals this man is a carpenter why
well you use as a carpenter's tool what
then is that to do with the case this
man is a musician for he sings what does
that have to do with the case this man
is a philosopher why because he wears a
rough Logan lawn here what about other
people
what did hedge priests wear same thing
this is why when a man sees someone of
them must be
he immediately says see what the
philosopher is doing and in a certain
respect they're not to be blamed for
that because how else are they going to
judge you know the same thing happens by
the way when people are complaining
about academic philosophers and what
goes on in a philosophy class I have so
many people who I run into and I talk to
you and they say what's what's your job
and I say well I teach philosophy or
anything I'll say other things having to
do with philosophy and they say I took a
philosophy class it was terrible and and
you know that's because their professor
gave them what would that betina's would
say a very bad impression of what it
meant to be a philosopher and why hey
why wouldn't they just judge on that
basis so he goes on he says if the prime
conception and profession of the
philosophers to wear a ruff cloak and
long hair the statement of these people
would be correct but if it is rather
than this to be free from error why do
they not take away from him the
designation of philosopher because he
does not fulfill the profession of one
this is really key it's not enough to be
a particular profession just to call
yourself that or to have other people
call you that were to wear the garb of
that in order to really have that role
and to fulfill it right you have to have
certain qualities you might say which
then are displayed in action so the
philosopher in quotes who's not behaving
like a philosopher really isn't a
philosopher according to epictetus what
should a philosopher be concerned with
well I picked Edith says being a
philosopher is a matter of the function
that the person does and he gives us a
lot of characterizations throughout that
works I'm going to read you a few of
them in here but let's let's actually
focus on what he's got here he says the
subject-matter of the philosophy is
reason using reason properly perfecting
our rational faculty also working on the
Faculty of choice the pro I racist that
which is really at the core of the human
person the good and the bad
other people may be mistaken about the
good
they have but the philosophers job is to
actually get these matters right to
study them to learn from putting this
into action and then if possible if
needed them to teach people but first
and foremost to get these manners right
in his or her own life so he goes on he
says when somebody when somebody sees a
fellow hearing clumsily with an axe
he doesn't say what's the use of
carpentry right when when the study says
this fellow is no carpenter for a he
hews clumsily with the axe
similarly when a man hears somebody's
singing badly he doesn't say all those
musicians they're terrible
rather they say this person isn't a
musician but it's only in the case of
philosophy that men behave like this
when they see somebody acting contrary
to the profession of the philosopher
they do not take away from him the
designation of philosopher but assuming
that he is falando philosopher they
taking from what goes on that he is
misbehaving they conclude that there's
no good in being a philosopher
philosophy doesn't accomplish anything
it's just a pointless exercise maybe
something that you know allows people
they have a certain prestige alone many
cases it doesn't get you very much he
says what what's the reason for this and
here we get back to the issue of
function we respect a prime conception
of the carpenter and the musician of all
the other artisans and artists well we
do not respect that of the philosopher
but as if it were confused and
inarticulate in our minds we judge it it
only from externals if we don't have a
clear conception of what it means to
actually be a philosopher it's
understandable that we are going to go
by externals does somebody possess a
philosophy degree from an accredited
university I guess they're a philosopher
then I can tell you that there are many
people who have degrees from from
prestigious institutions and are
currently teaching who are not by any
means anything close but the thing is
calling a
they may not even meet minimal standards
in other ways as well but it's
understandable that the general public
would be taken in by that isn't and it's
understandable that somebody who really
doesn't understand what the profession
is about the loss to jump into that
would likewise be confused Epictetus is
not saying a terrible thing he's saying
let's actually get this matter right so
he goes on and he says what is the
subject matter for the philosopher it's
not a rough flow it's reason what is the
end for the philosopher it's not to wear
a ruff cloak but rather to keep the
reason right what is the nature of his
principles they don't have to do with
the the question of how to grow a long
beard or if they kind of hair do they
know rather as Zeno says to understand
the elements of reason what the nature
of each one is and how they are fit in
one to another and all the consequences
of these facts so that's just one
characterization of what the function of
the philosopher actually is another way
that he talks about it
in other places is that the philosopher
is concerned with a particular art but
it's a more general art or or discipline
the art of being human the artist of
filling our duties as a human being
comporting ourselves right in accordance
with human nature as such or another way
of looking at this the art of living not
just living though living well living
freely living tranquil living in such a
way that we can actually attain what it
is that we desire and not fall into what
it is that we are averse to that is what
philosophy is fundamentally focused on
according to Epictetus so the
philosopher the test for whether
somebody really is a philosopher is to
look at the kind of life that they're
reading and see whether it actually
matches up to the principles that he or
she is articulating and claiming are
essential another thing that he says
that's
very interesting this is in book three
is that we shouldn't be as he says like
children who are playing at things we
have to make a commitment we have to
make a decision so he says this is where
he's talking about people wanting to
like get into philosophy as as we say he
says think about what you're getting
into people is a heard a philosopher and
heard someone speaking like Euphrates
and then epictetus says but who can talk
like him right he's praising him they
wish to be philosophers themselves first
consider what the business is and then
your own natural ability what you can
bear if you want to be a wrestler take a
look at your body do you have the body
for it one manís of natural talent for
one thing another for another makes us
do you suppose that you can do the
things that you do now and also be a
philosopher do you suppose you can eat
in the same fashion drink in the same
fashion give way to anger and irritation
just as you do now you must keep vigils
work hard overcome certain desires
abandon them be despised by a paltry
slay me laugh to scorn by those who meet
you look at these drawbacks decide
whether this is really for you nowadays
we might say do you want to go and study
philosophy in a professional manner
well think about whether you want to
take on student death think about how
you want to be situated in relation to
the rest of the economy and the people
who are going to look at things in
economic terms we could go on and on
from this and then he says you know if
you're ready for that
then go ahead and do it otherwise don't
approach don't act like a child now a
philosopher later on a tax gatherer that
a rhetorician that a procurator of
Caesar these things don't go together
it's just like any other profession if
you want to be a great musician there
are some things you can't do I mean
here's here's one
an example and I'm not a great musician
I'm actually just a mediocre musician
but I'm a musician who plays stringed
instruments and I can't play both of
them at the same time unless I decide
I'm gonna change what I what I do I used
to play bass guitar and you where down
here your fingernails by doing that of
course I could use a pic but I didn't
want to use a pic and currently I play
banjo - playing banjo and you want to
use your fingers you actually need
fingernails can't play bass and banjo at
the same time because either you're
gonna have fingernails and you're going
to use them for the banjo or you're
going to play bass and that's gonna tear
your finger fingernails up because of
those strings sometimes actually you
know where the skin down your fingers I
used to play that much it's like that
with other things - if you want to be
the musician you need to put in hours
and hours of practice if you if you want
to be good if you want to make a living
at it if you want to have the facility
to do what it is that you desire and to
avoid what it is that you're averse to
like sounding terrible or missing your
cues or things like that
similarly with philosophy if you
actually want to do well in philosophy
you'd have to choose certain things and
leave other things out it's it's you
know there was a kind of requirement now
philosophy will provide guidance for
that and some of that gets clearer as
you go on with it but all of that gets
overlooked by those who you know
misidentify the philosophy in its
essence with externals
Epictetus also says and this is where
i'm going to sort of wrap this up that
we shouldn't get upset about the fact
that people do in fact misidentify
philosophy and philosophers with you
know the external appearance of it that
is to be expected and we don't have
control over that it would be a little
bit weird if we were grasping what it is
to be a philosopher and then not
behaving like a philosopher in the face
of people getting mixed
about what philosophy is